welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show thank you for tuning in I'm
gonna start with a quote this one is
from Steve Jobs your time is limited so
don't waste it living someone else's
life
good advice the second thing I'm going
to give you to start off is a probably
useless way to remember how large Mount
Fuji is and that's twelve thousand three
hundred and sixty-five feet in terms of
altitude and the way you remember that
is twelve months in a year 365 days in a
year so you're welcome this episode
features Dan Carlin Dan Carlin is hugely
impressive to me which is obvious when
you listen to my initial ramblings and I
am clearly nervous and I stumble over a
bunch of words which is hilarious so I
hope you enjoy that awkwardness dan has
done many things in his life he's been
on radio he's been on television but the
way I came to know him was through hard
core history which is an incredible
podcast and you should put aside for the
moment any reservations or doubts you
have about a podcast based on history of
course this podcast Tim Ferriss show is
about deconstructing excellence and if
you listen to one episode of hardcore
history you will realize how absolutely
stupendous and amazing Dan Carlin is so
we we get into among other things his
early beginnings stumbling in the
beginning first versions of the podcast
how he grew into it as a full-time
profession his influences his habits his
rituals the things that he would do
differently the things that he would
tell himself when he was 20 years old
and on and on none the point being to
pull out tactics routines tools that you
can use not only in podcasting but well
outside of podcasting makes people who
are good in a particular arena tend to
have a lot in common with people who are
the best in other arenas as always this
podcast is supported by you guys so if
you do like this podcast please visit
4-hour workweek dot-com forward slash
ebooks that is the home of the Tim
Ferriss book club where I list a handful
of books that have had a huge impact on
my life my career
and I guarantee you will be extremely
impressed and happy with them it's not
too many and they'll link through to
Amazon where you can take a look at
these various books and audiobooks so
it's four hour work week comm forward
slash books without further adieu hope
you enjoy the podcast and thanks for
listening at this altitude I can once I
have for a half-mile before my hands
shake welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show ladies and gentlemen
and I have a treat for you we have Dan
Carlin on the phone and Dan I have to
tell you I have had some fantastic folks
on this podcast so far and I've met a
lot of people in my life and I have been
so nervous about this particular
conversation for weeks now and the part
of the reason is there are very few
podcasts that I actually listen to on a
regular basis and I'm hoping that by the
end of this conversation everyone who
listens to this well at the very least
listen to one full episode of hardcore
history and this is somewhat akin given
that I'm a novice and the podcasting
arena to me getting in front of a crowd
of tens or hundreds of thousands of
people and trying to say have a pass
with a famous NFL quarterback or do a
foul shot competition with the top NBA
player or something like that I've been
so impressed by the quality of your
podcast and we've talked about this
before recognizing the amount of time
and energy that you put into each one of
these and we'll jump into things in a
second but just as context I had asked a
number of my very close friends were
involved with audio production and
podcasts as well as video what their
favorite podcasts were and almost
without exception hardcore history was
listed in the top three for every single
person and of course the first question
I asked myself was how could a history
podcast be one of the most popular
podcasts out
and I remember downloading the very
first episode that I heard of hardcore
history which was the prophets of doom
and I looked at the length and I think
it's well over four hours if I'm not
mistaken and I remember thinking to
myself I'm gonna download this I'm going
to just get a taste for it for the first
five to ten minutes to see if I can
learn anything about the style and then
that's gonna be it
and I have digested now dozens and
dozens and dozens of hours of your
content so first and foremost thank you
for putting so much effort into each of
these episodes I don't always know how
to react to such nice things that people
say I mean it's a fantastic compliment
and I always tell people that I would
love everyone in their lives to get that
feeling of that something you did was so
well received by people it's it's I feel
very fortunate and a little like I
stumbled into this and like you can't
even really take credit for it you just
kind of fall into something that after
you fall into it seems like where you
should have been all along so I feel
like a really lucky guy to have stumbled
into something that seems to be so well
received I appreciate that and yeah for
hours I mean if you told me when we
started doing hardcore history that I
was gonna be doing for our shows I think
I would have canceled right then and
there so now that I don't want to listen
to it I didn't want it to do so that's
actually where I was hoping to start
naturally at the beginning and give
people a little bit of background on how
hardcore history came to be because I
remember you mentioned in a previous
conversation that it started off very
very differently so I'm curious to know
how it came to be and what your
expectations were at the time because
certainly it's it's become an entity
unto itself and it's it's turned into
something very very big but how did it's
how did it come together and how did it
start off well maybe other podcasters
listening to you will be able to relate
to this I've started a lot of shows in
my life and a lot of them were radio
shows and whatnot and the one thing you
learn when you start these shows is that
all you can do is come up with a concept
and then try to take that concept where
you think it should go initially
and then once you do that whatever you
creates going to evolve and some of that
evolution is in your control and some of
it isn't in your control I always say
find your favorite TV series take
something like Seinfeld for example and
then go look at the first five episodes
and you'll notice that it's not really
Seinfeld yet they haven't figured it
hasn't evolved into what really works
and they haven't find but then
eventually it finds its stride and so
when you listen to our early episodes
they don't sound a lot like what we're
doing now either and and I mean length
is a perfect example there was a time
where we were really scared of
approaching an hour-long program and we
used I remember one time it was with our
Apache tears episode the ones we did on
the Apaches and we were approaching an
hour and then I got a finished product
it was like 1 hour and 15 minutes and I
said we're cancelling this show we have
to have to dial it back over an hour
because no one will listen and so I
think the fact that the audience had
proven receptive gave us a feeling that
there was some freedom here to go a
little farther and then a little farther
and I'm shocked that everybody can
listen to it that long editing it for us
we dread hearing it over and over
so I'm really not on the same wavelength
with a lot of the listeners well
speaking as someone who's written a 420
page book than Aden 592 page book and
then a 670 citria Lee does take on a
life of its own and I'm really glad you
brought up the Seinfeld example because
I remember looking at say some of the
the current versions of podcasts when I
when I was considering doing my own
looking at some of your newer episodes
looking at some of the more polished Joe
Rogan episodes which are also monsters
looking at many different types and then
someone recommended that I go back and
look at say the first 1 or 2 episodes
that Joe did on video and there
hilariously amateur really really
hilarious and if I hadn't done that I
think I would have been too intimidated
to get started because I would have
falsely assumed
that the polished format that you've
arrived at is where you started and that
that reflects an intrinsic ability that
I entirely lack which could also still
be true but what I'd love to know is
with hardcore history in particular and
we'll talk about the podcast I also want
to talk about history but were there any
particular tipping points that that
helped you start to form it into what it
is now and I'm sure it's still evolving
but were there any particular tipping
points whether it was in popularity
specific episodes aha moments that come
to mind for you content or format wise I
think we had ideas when we started it of
things we wanted to do and then a couple
shows into it you could start to sense
that these were elements that you should
have in every single episode so for
example somewhere along the line I'd
always had these these sort of Twilight
Zone kind of ideas about history and
when we could start to say okay every
episode really is successful if it has
some of those some of the drama some of
the narrative some of so you start to
figure out what the ingredients in your
creation are and once that's the case
then you can start to say it's not so
much a formula as a checklist and saying
right okay every good episode that we do
should have a B C D and E and I'm not
sure when you start that you're totally
aware of that you're still playing
around with the ingredients and the mix
and and we still do that I mean each
episode is gonna sound different because
we want to put extra cumin in this one
and less hot sauce in that one but but
at the same time you don't really know
what's working in the first few episodes
and so somewhere somewhere around like
we did one called step stories early on
which is sort of a loose look at all the
different people and the culture and
history of the of the giant flat area
you know that starts in Eastern Europe
and goes almost all the way to the
Pacific Ocean and we did a show like
that and it was the first time I think
we hit the sweet spot with all those
elements in it and when you heard it you
just said okay that that's significantly
better than anything else we've done and
that's what you said there we go okay
well we figured out how to do this kind
of and we're gonna start to not
mass-produce it but we're gonna make
or that we do a better job in every
later episode that incorporates all
these things that we think start have
started to blend well I am currently
listening or I should say re listening
to the wrath of the cons which is a a
audiobook or three worth of content in
and of itself and it seems like having
pulled my beat a five hundred thousand
or so people on Twitter that that is one
of the most popular series so to speak
and I'm curious to know if there are any
episodes that you thought were going to
be a huge hit that were not or if there
any episodes that were completely out of
left field a huge a huge home run well
it's nice to hear you say that because I
think I left a little bit of my sanity
with that wrath of the con series and
the truth is is that the longer
multi-part series where we take on some
big issue that takes four or six
episodes hours long each and you have an
audiobook at the end to do are so
challenging because you have all these
loose threads that developed while
you're doing the story and then by the
time you hit the middle of the series
you have to start tying those threads
together and it becomes you know I'm in
one of these things now we're talking
about the first world war and we're in
episode 4 and all of a sudden the whole
thing is unraveling in front of my face
and it does it just had challenged your
sanity a bit I'm always surprised when
the shows are well received so I don't
have any where I was going oh this is
gonna be a home run I'm always sure I
screwed up one way or the other so it's
never never happens that I'm sure it's a
hit oftentimes I release something and I
just brace myself for what I'm sure is
gonna be this negative response prophets
of doom that you like I didn't think at
the end where I said I heard it yeah it
was like a disclaimer saying this didn't
come out the way I wanted and people
liked it anyway so that's usually what
happened I'm a little bit more of a
perfectionist I I was reading a book the
other day on the Rolling Stones and they
have this picture in it of their
guitarist Keith Richards just hanging
over this audio board and you can see
he's been up for like days and they're
and they're on like the hundredth take
of this song and this album is overdue
and the hold and I thought to myself
it's not all that different than what
we're doing
so so I'm always sure that this next
show we're gonna release is gonna
destroy our brand forever and then I'm
never gonna live up to the hype and that
I'm the sanity is has been left in the
studio somewhere prophets of doom is a
perfect example the Apache tears show
where we I think it was the first one
either we were near or over an hour
I was sure people were gonna freak out
about that so pretty much every episode
I released I'm sure that's the end we
screwed it up
and you mentioned the aspect of tying
loose ends together and this is
something I feel very familiar with just
having put together books with multiple
storylines and dozens of different
components however with the printed word
I have the luxury of being able to go
back copy and paste cut out sections
translate them to other areas but with
audio after you've recorded say two
three episodes you really have to work
with I would imagine on some level what
you've already done so I'd love to hear
how on earth you prepare for these
things what the process currently looks
like because when I listen to the
prophets of doom and at the end like you
said the disclaimer came out where you
say that it didn't really turn out the
way you expected it to or wanted it to
and that you'd you'd actually recorded
and I have to just hear it from the
horse's mouth here I recorded a complete
version of that episode that you then
scrapped
I just couldn't fathom taking the time
to record that and then scrap it and
start over I mean it just blew my mind
so could you talk a little bit about the
process how do you research how do you
choose topics when you're going after an
episode like this
because it sounds very masterfully
delivered so one of the the thoughts
that occurred to me for instance was how
often do you stop like how long is it
take in other words and so on and so
forth so that I'd love for you to just
discuss if you would be open to it to
kind of start to finish what the process
looks like for putting one of these
shows together well let me back up
because you talked about doing a book
and and and there are there are
similarities when you do these really
long podcasts especially these series we
have a name for it in-house I call it
the Blue Room
and the in the Blue Room is when you've
heard the piece so often and this
happens with reading to us I'm sure you
have the same problem with books where
you where you've now seen it so often
that you lose the ability to absorb it
the way a new listener would or a new
reader would definitely and it destroys
your ability to judge what you have so I
mean it's the only time I get jealous of
like the TV networks and stuff where
they're able to bring in test audiences
and show them something that they put
together and just say okay so what's
your reaction to this because they have
the same problem waiting right they get
the Blue Room but they have the chance
to expose a few people to it and say
okay is this good
we've lost all sense of direction on
this now the bad part of that is then
you can then the audience can start
driving it you don't want that either
from a creative sense but when we hit
where we are in this show now I haven't
the slightest idea if it even makes
sense anymore like you hear something
you go this sounds remarkably similar to
something I think I said seven hours ago
and so you said at least it's easier to
do that in the written sense but the
same problem exists so when you say how
do you do these things the reason it
gets complicated where we are now is
that I have to write some of that stuff
down and say no you talked about this
already don't talk about this again
right as opposed to saying what I'm
gonna do and it's part of keeping the
you know don't cross the streams like
they said in ghostbusters it's trying
not to cross tangents and streams and
and and the only part that's a saving
grace in the episode we're doing now is
in the First World War
things are repetitive and it's actually
a part of the story that's how people at
the time felt like oh my god we're still
going through the same it's the same
movie over and over again so if I make
the listeners feel that way in the show
I can the cop out is gonna be able to
say and I'm going to say it well now you
feel just like the people in the story
so if I sound repetitive we were after
that um so that's how I do it I really
do I pick subjects that I already know
about mm-hmm and then I begin the
research from there cuz I always tell
people someone will say can you please
talk about the history of Southeast
India or something and I'll say you
don't want me to talk about I don't know
anything about
and you can't educate yourself to a
reasonable standard in the short period
of time we have I have it's enough for
me to pick a subject I know a lot about
I know a lot about the First World War
and I've read 50 books since we started
this thing on top of that what's amazing
to me is how much has changed since I
thought I learned about these things
maybe maybe the 1980s I I I was really
into that subject for a few years and
you go back and you think well there
can't be that much more about this
100-year old subject since then you
couldn't be more wrong
right there's books and revisions and
new points of view and it's it's insane
so I picked these topics I already have
a good foundation for and I've thrown
away by the way you talk about throwing
away shows I threw away a show on the
Greeks and the ancient Persians I think
I threw away one of the Apache show so
I've done this before but I pick up
something I know a bunch about and I I
think about it and this is the thing
that listeners never give me any time
for because basically I'm behind
schedule would I start mm-hmm and the
listeners are always wondering what I'm
doing but you actually have to sit down
a little bit and think and just and just
sit in the shower and just go what's
weird about this story and what turns me
on you know that's where you come up
with these weird sort of things and and
those things are the pillars we sort of
build the show around I always say it's
a little like our style is a jazz like
or Led Zeppelin used to have a line for
how they constructed their work they
said they said our format is tight but
loose and that's artists is where where
there are these mileposts that I set
that I want to get to but within those
mileposts I have all this room to sort
of you know go off on a yeah guitar solo
for a long period of time or like
tangents if you can't stand tangents you
can't listen to my stuff because that's
I mean it's like the tangents or maybe
the pillar of the show we just go off on
all these avenues you couldn't structure
it if you tried to write it out that way
it wouldn't work but I think it does
come across perhaps as disjointed
sometimes or maybe this solos gone on
too long and we need to get back to the
format or whatever but I do I go into
the studio with kind of a concept and an
approach I want to try
to make work and it doesn't always work
out and I'll go in there and usually I'm
you know coffee used to work so much
better for me in the old days but but a
bunch of cups of coffee I'll get in
there and I'll just start talking about
it and usually it's pretty good for a
while and then it breaks down at some
point and that's where I'll stop and
then I'll pick up from just before it
broke down the session before and we'll
try to string something together now
sometimes I'll go and listen I'll go oh
wow we really left this part out or oh
that's I there's a mistake in there we
have to fix and so there's going back
and pulling the Rolling Stones in the in
the studio obsessing over take 99 of you
know one of their songs and we do some
of that now too and we do a lot more
than we used to because when you're
doing four and five hour episodes you
can't keep it straight so we're
constantly relisting to the stuff and
it's become a lot more structured than
it used to be I used to be able to walk
in there and say if we get lucky I'll
walk out in the studio with a whole
hardcore history show for you that
doesn't happen anymore so she's gonna
run out of gas I guess is what I'm
saying and when you're planning let's
just say a single episode not a series
but a single episode that could be two
to four hours in length how much of what
I hear as a listener is scripted out is
written out in long-form what are your
prompts look like are your props so to
speak because I'm thinking about how I
prepare for say a keynote presentation
is 60 even a keynote presentation there
are cases where I'll have portions that
are verbatim that I'll memorize just for
delivery sake say at the beginning in
the very end then there are in some
cases bullet points that I use to break
say a section into into three parts so
that it's easier to rehearse as well as
as nail repeatedly well I've been
mystified trying to figure out because
I'm just purely guessing what you have
in front of you when you're recording
and sort of generally speaking how often
you take breaks for instance say 10
minutes 20 minutes 30 minutes what does
that look like these days when you're
doing a single episode as opposed to a
series well I hope you can tell that
there is no script because there is
there is no script and that and we hope
that that's why it sounds natural like
it does
well the only reason that I ask is
because it's it sounds so polished
without the UM x' and ahhs and I'm
accustomed to hearing for almost
everyone that I've ever heard in
long-form conversation that it just
seemed like a superpower to not have a
script I guess going on there I mean I'm
sure that we've taken out some ohms and
things like that before
but I mean you know I did radio for a
dozen years before I did podcast and I
did television before then and thumbs
are a pretty basic thing you work on it
doesn't mean we're um free it just means
that I'm less likely to pull and um then
I might have been and I always said you
know we kind of had an advantage when we
got into podcasting well first of all we
got in so early it was a little like the
Oklahoma land rush right it was nice to
get in there so early and sort of claim
your little zone but also I wasn't
learning how to do proper mic technique
you know I was starting at a little bit
of an advantage and so with the arms
fall into that category a little bit in
terms of um I mean we do write down for
example if I've got a twisty idea that I
want to make sure to include I might
write down the twisty idea and then post
that up on the cork board to remind
myself that in this 20 minute segment
today you want to hit that idea I also
find you know what you call primary
source accounts so somebody's in the
first world war and there's they talk
about what it's like in the trenches and
I'll know that I have that piece and so
I'll have a note that says okay page 246
of this book you know and I'll have
marked that guy is quote and so I'll
know I have that and but I don't know
exactly when I'm gonna get to it I just
know that's that somewhere in today's
session you're probably going to run
into the point where it's logical to put
that primary source quote in hmm so that
that's how I organize it otherwise it's
it's a free-form
sort of improvisational talk god it's
amazing I want to give people a couple
of different options for places to start
with hardcore history because it really
I'm seldom as impressed as I have been
with the entire show but stop it dude
yeah I know I'm making things awkward
there are a lot of good people out there
but I've sort of gotten stuck on
hardcore history so I feel like I need
to satisfy that fix first but one thing
I think that you do very very well and
I'd like to ask you how much of this was
learned over time and also I'll get to
the second part but you do a very good
job of pulling listeners into the
episodes and the example that jumps to
mind is you might have a description say
in the case of wrath of the Khans of
some of the historical context some of
the the various cultures and step
communities in different areas and then
you'll say you know imagine if you will
that you have an entire army comprised
of circus trick archers and then not
only do they have bows but the bows are
a hundred and thirty pound pole which
happens to mean more to me these days
because I've been playing around with
archery and I know how hard it is at
least for me to repeatedly pull say a 55
or 60 pound bow so the fact that they
get Unleashed you know 60 hours a minute
or whatever was but you pull people in
with the you know imagine if you were
and then doing hypotheticals with of
course the Martians and so on the verbal
delivery that you have which is very
polished and of course you've done a lot
of radio and a lot of television but if
someone feels self-conscious about their
own vocal delivery and they want to
podcast maybe I'm projecting here but
how would you suggest that people work
on that skill and try to refine their
delivery to get a little closer to what
I would consider very very professional
in your case well I appreciate you
saying that because I I came up in radio
at a time the tail end of what maybe you
could call the big voice era where radio
was still this won't mean anything to
all of the young listeners but like a
Gary Owens deep you know classical
almost stereotypical old-fashioned
broadcaster style with the deep pipes or
the way the guys used to describe their
voices and when I came up I remember the
boss at the radio station where I worked
I mean at one time he actually suggested
I have like
adenoids surgery or something good baby
get that deep voice that that was the
classic that they were looking for and
I'm not only didn't have that I didn't
want that I just wanted to talk the way
I talk and then somewhere while I was
doing that that whole deep voice thing
went out of fashion and everybody was
more looking for a unique you were
looking for your own voice right a
unique voice that sounded like no one
else and luckily just having your own
voice as long as it didn't grate like
nails on a blackboard which some people
said mine did so it's it's an acquired
taste maybe but having your own voice
became the real preferred for me and all
of a sudden everybody is saying gosh
it's so great you have your own voice
and all I'm thinking about is all those
years that that was the one thing
everybody didn't want me to have so when
you say to a listener how do you get
more polished and broadcaster like
there's a process you're gonna go
through if you start podcasting or
whatever will you figure out what your
voice is and it shouldn't be something
fake it should be your voice but maybe
you take it down a range maybe because
we've all got a vocal range right from
the highest you speak to the lowest you
speak there may be a sweet spot in there
and it might not be the way you always
talk or you or you might want to talk in
that in that tone more I think
personally that there is no perfect
voice and I think that that as long as
as you like it and you sound the way you
want to sound that that's especially in
this world I mean what I love about the
podcasts and the the Internet is that
there's so many potential people out
there listening that if you just be
yourself you're going to attract
listeners who like that and then you
never have to fool around with trying to
be someone else to please your audience
because the people you've attracted are
there because they like you already
right I don't think you should try to
develop some style other than just
polish your own style the ohms are a
perfect example but listen I bet if you
wanted to you could weave that into your
style where that's almost your thing
right I mean we talk around here a lot
about turning negatives into positives
or lemons into lemonade or creatively
taking a weak spot and making it a
strong spot I always was heavily in the
red as they say when I was on the radio
where
I yelled so loud and I still do that the
meter just jumps up into the red and
they would say Union you need to speak
in this one zone of loudness or you'll
screw up the radio stations compression
well after a while I just started
writing liners for the big voice guide
as new here's Dan Carlin he talks so
loud or whatever that's my style I meant
to do that and it's a matter of fact if
you do it you're imitating me so it's
partly taking what you already do and
saying no no this isn't a negative this
is the thing I bring to the table buddy
right no I copyrighted that I talk real
loud and then I talk really quietly and
if you have a problem with that well you
don't understand what a good style is
Tim I like that I will I will I think i
shall capitalize on that right your
fault it reminded me of actually an
experience that I had with writing the
4-hour workweek but it was my first book
I was very nervous about it and when I
first started and I'm not sure how many
people know this I wrote the first four
or five chapters and ended throwing them
all out because I was writing in this
very pompous sort of Ivy League style
that I thought sounded very smart and it
came off stilted and it just it was very
unattractive so I tossed it and then I
tried to write in an amusing fashion I
thought I needed to be funny so I was
like all right I'll be funny I should
stop being so serious and it came across
very slapstick Three Stooges so yet
again I had to take these four or five
chapters that I'd spent weeks on and
throw them out and ultimately found my
own voice which was really just
discovering something that was latent
and that people felt in conversation by
having two glasses of wine and starting
to write as if it were an email to two
specific friends and that is when I
finally found the proper balance which
was intrinsically how I spoke to my
close friends about serious subjects
after a couple of glasses of wine was
there a point and also brings to mind
there's a friend of mine named Gary
Vaynerchuk who became well known after
doing something called Wine Library TV
and if you look at the very first say 10
episodes especially the first few
he's really subdued and you learn later
of course he sort of grown into himself
and he has a very bombastic style but
that's who Gary is but it took him a
long time to get there and were there
any sort of points for you aside from
embracing this this extremely flexible
vocal range that you talked about where
you kind of got comfortable in your own
shoes and were able to not no longer
conform to other expectations people had
of what a good se radio host was or
podcaster well if you go listen to even
my earlier podcast the one thing you're
gonna notice is I talked faster I was
louder I was more aggressive and all and
people go and listen to it now and go
god when did you slow down or I'm glad
you slowed down or something like that
and I always say but it wasn't it wasn't
intentional I just got older and the
coffee doesn't work as well yet and yet
it slowed me down to a level that more
people are comfortable with than the way
I used to be but it wasn't intentional I
mean I would have been perfectly happy
attracting whatever audience liked that
style more but I think there's a natural
aging and I mean I think you hear it
with singers or anyone else where the
style doesn't change because the singer
doesn't like singing the way that they
used to sing they just their voice is
different and their energy is different
and luckily for me me getting older and
slower and and mellower is easier on
more listeners I guess than the style I
had when I was younger I'll tell you
what I miss as I get older
you know I've gotten to the age now
where where sometimes I'll reach for
some fact or something that's in my
memory banks and it takes longer to get
than it used to in the old days I was so
fast and it wasn't just vocally it was
it was indicative of how fast my brain
was working and my mouth was trying to
keep up with my brain and now my brain
is slowed down and so and so I feel like
an athlete whose past their prime right
who say I used to be able to run a 4-3
forty man and now I can't do it anymore
but the people like it slower so in a
funny way I've aged to a point where
more people are comfortable listening to
my middle-age style than they were
listening to me when when they used to
call me the angry young wolf back on if
you can believe that
could be worse could be worse that's
that's that was one of the better
nickname I took so who are some of your
favorite podcasters or radio
personalities or people on audio I guess
what I'd love to know are people who
have inspired you or people you admire
in the audio medium as it were
they could be Living Dead current
up-and-coming really doesn't matter but
I'd be curious to know who you have
looked up to or admire in that world
well I appreciate you saying Living Dead
long because here's the dirty little
secret of my life and it's very hard to
explain to people I do not consume much
media anymore that is not text-based
so people will say have you seen this
show or have you seen this movie or have
you listened to this podcast and I can
almost say with a hundred percent
certainty no and it's gonna get me into
trouble I tell other people I'm gonna
rip off some well-known movie or TV show
theme or something someday without
knowing that I've ripped it off you know
I almost did once I did this thing once
where I I had this great comparison for
this one episode we did and somebody who
listened to it before I released it
thank goodness had to tell me that I was
just giving the listeners the plot of
avatar which was which was the big movie
out there that I hadn't seen and I
thought that's a great way to stumble
into a copyright infringement or look
like you're ripping somebody off so I
haven't really consumed media in a long
time and it's not on purpose I just I'm
not in a place in my life where I have
that kind of time right now but of
course we were all influenced by people
I had a in the same way you were talking
about how much you're you know you like
interviewing me well I like interviewing
people and I like to interview James
Burke and we did in the show the guy who
was the famous host of the connection
series hmm oh yeah the day the universe
changed in an Irish guy and as someone
with the Irish genes myself and I
admired Burke from a long time ago in
the way his wonderful mind thought in
the way he would he would string ideas
together and so for me you know Gwen
Dyer we had Gwen Dyer in the program in
the Canadian journalists who did a
wonderful series when I was growing up
on war that got me where I live
somewhere deeply you know III was an old
when I was a TV reporter I was on a CBS
affiliate and at CBS the the soul of
Edward our Murrow sort of runs deep and
so those of us who were serious about
reporting which was not all of us took a
real I mean that was a really important
thing for people especially of a
tradition history minded kind of thing
to look up to and to shoot for I mean
you know sometimes you aspire to be
things that you know you can never quite
achieve but the attempt to reach those
Heights even if you fall short is a good
goal to set and so those are the kind of
people that I look up to and I think a
lot of times when we're doing especially
the hardcore history podcast you look at
people like Orson Welles and people who
were involved in audio when audio was
the main medium and say that those
people did a lot of things that we could
recreate again when you talk about like
a theater of the mind approach
little-known fact
we used to do theater the mind stuff on
the older history shows and and if you
listen really carefully with it's crazy
cuz we put this immense amount of effort
it's hard to even describe how much
effort basically composing an audio
score for these episodes but we wanted
to make it optional so that you didn't
have to hear the score if you didn't
want to so we made so we because we
didn't know if it was a plus or a minus
and we thought it might be a plus to the
people who liked it but a minus to the
people who didn't so we made it so quiet
that you literally have to put your
headphones on and crank it up and get
into it you have candles on or whatever
the listeners do and then you can enjoy
it but if you're in your car or on the
bus or what you won't hear it and people
love that it was all theater than mine
and that's the way I loved it too I mean
if I could do it anyway again I would
throw the theater and the optional
theater the mind stuff back in it
but it was like doing an episode after
you'd already finished an episode I mean
we'd have to do the show and then score
the show and it just at a certain point
in order to free up I mean we already
weren't getting shows out fast enough we
had to drop that but if I could ever do
it the way I want to again I would go
back to scoring the shows with Sam
defects and little hums and drones and
because we've got hole I mean you can go
back and listen a bunch of our shows
have all these it's not quite put on The
Wizard of Oz at the same time we start
the podcast and you'll follow along but
there's we do a lot of fun stuff that I
miss I mean in bubonic nooks mm-hmm the
one we did on the Black Plague my
favorite part of that whole episode is
at the very end we're talking about how
you may think that this is a long time
ago but you know it might not be as long
as you think and then we have the sound
really quiet in the background of a
laboratory beaker dropping and then you
hear hear a Red Alert alarm going off
like like you just the CDC lost a flu
virus or something and so I used to love
the potential of throwing in the Orson
Welles theater them line type stuff and
so when I look back on on the Great's of
the past at this point I'm almost
looking back at them the way Led
Zeppelin looked at bluesman that they
could rip off I'm trying to find little
techniques that I can steal that they
used to do but but yeah so I mean I
wouldn't say that there are specific
individuals as much as oh my gosh that's
a great show well that's a great idea
so I'm not listening to a great song and
listen to a great riff and going oh I
love that little drumbeat right in there
I could rip that off or you know so
right now that that's more influential
to me than any particular broadcast but
yeah I love so much growing up obviously
mm-hmm you mentioned texts I am a really
avid reader loved books always have and
it's clear that you do a ton of research
for these shows a couple questions
related to books what is the book that
you've given most as a gift to other
people oh my goodness or books yeah you
know I have to tell you the truth I
don't do that either and people say to
me all the time can you recommend a book
for a B or C and I rarely do because I'm
not reading general stuff a lot of times
I'm reading really weird sort of books
that would like like you get into this
world war one subject that I'm into now
so then you're fighting these weird
little things that aren't gonna mean
anything to someone unless they've read
some of the other books that I read
before that so my stuff is not real
useful to people I'm trying to think
what if anything I gave
and I'm a really horrible gift giver to
Tim thanks for exposing all of my
business here publicly that's what
that's why my wife is so fantastic a
gift giving she makes up for me okay no
answer all right no no problem that's a
bad gift giver are there any all right
let's take a different tack give any
favorite documentaries or movies I know
you don't consume a lot of media these
days but what I'm trying to figure out
is what and maybe this is a separate
question but what made you so fascinated
in history and I know you've studied it
before but for a lot of people they take
the the viewpoint that well histories in
the past I don't feel like getting into
esoteric aspects of old civilizations
when I should be focusing on ABC theory
of course there's a lot of practicality
I think in studying quite a bit of
history which tends to repeat itself but
I'm trying to identify for someone who
is not aside from listening to the
podcast of course which i think is the
easiest answer to get someone hooked on
history even indirectly are there any
documentaries movies books anything that
come to mind that's a bunch of different
questions it is let me take them one at
a time
um some of the movies that I I enjoy
watching it's so perverse and to bring
them up because they're they're not good
movies a lot of times like for example I
tell my wife if it has time travel in it
I'm likely to watch it whether or not I
have any interest in I mean that's what
gets me forget about oh this is a great
film I have to I'll give you a perfect
example there was a movie I think they
did it in late 1970s or maybe 1980 I
think it came out called the final
countdown and it's relatively horrible
as well he goes but it doesn't matter
the story is about what if a modern
aircraft carrier went back to the eve of
the Pearl Harbor attack and and so it's
taking on Japanese zeroes with modern
airplanes and forget it the story can
suck now I'm in right all I need okay I
don't care see so so so that's a perfect
example it may be that we grab you just
okay conceptually I'm all-in
right
you don't even have to execute it lizard
with our podcast we kind of go there
sometimes do hopefully these twists are
enough to disguise the fact maybe we
didn't tie this other thought together
so well or I go off on too many tangents
the other point about I mean you're I
think you're striving to try to find how
the history bug got started in me and I
think we've been trying to figure that
out in my family forever my mother's
concept is that I was somehow born with
it because I was into it at such a you
know me you you could give me history
related things at Christmas when I'm
four and I'm into it and there's no
explanation I just think you have to
suggest that a lot of us are hardwired
to like this or that and in my case you
know I mean some people you give a
musical instrument to and oh my god
they're four years old and they're
playing like a teenager for me it was it
was stuff from the past and I don't know
but I've been into it since I was very
little which is it's always so weird to
me to be able to make a living doing
something that's what I mean when I when
we started this conversation I said you
know I've really been fortunate to fall
into something that you almost seem to
have been born to do and I don't know
how I got so lucky but everybody should
have this feeling you know to feel like
God I catching a football is just I've
been doing that since I was two it's the
thing I knew best in life and somebody
gave me a job catching a football so I
mean that's how I feel that then there's
a little bit you know when you talk
about being born to something I guess
what I do is storytelling because that's
what people tell me I do right there I
think there's a storytelling gene you
know and I think I think it runs in
families
I think the Irish people in my family
could tell a hell of a story long before
I was on this planet and if you're lucky
you get some of that and so I think
there's a bunch of those elements that
just work in in our favor and we're and
we're taking our strengths and running
with them and so when you talk about how
you put a podcast together one of the
things I would suggest that people do is
build it around what you do well you
know and so and so I feel like I'm just
utilizing whatever talents I was born
with and it's working out I mean that I
can do this instead of working on the
assembly line is one of the great gifts
in my life you know
it seems and please correct me if I'm
wrong that hardcore history at least has
existed since 2006 is that right you
might know better than I do something
along those someone I think the other
podcast is 2005 and hardcore history
comes some time after that right so you
this like you said you've you've been in
this game or in this medium for some
time when did it occur to you that you
might be able to do this full-time when
did that transition take place and when
was there a particular moment that
stands out to you when you realized that
people have been telling me for a long
time that we could do this long before I
thought we could do this I had a guy
hire me a tech guy hire me back in 96
off the radio to do our show on the
Internet and I look at him like he was
crazy because I did because what one the
internet wasn't that wasn't not only
wait to you there was that the
mechanisms didn't exist and he said well
that's what my company will do will
invent the mechanisms to do this and
you'll be like the test case right
you'll show people it never went
anywhere but ever since then the
discussion of how do we put Dan on the
Internet has been going on amongst
people that I just had to trust knew
better than I did about that um and and
the implication always was that you
would have more listeners cuz I was
always I was saying I was I was the the
messed up part of the radio stations
Dave part whenever I was on cuz I just
was a Martian I never fit
I mean I'm apparently was good enough to
stay employ but I never fit with
programming and so so the attitude was
that's what the Internet's for you'll be
able to reach this mass of people that
are above and beyond your normal talk
radio show demographic and and that
turned out to be true
but the implication was that if you had
a bunch of listeners you'd be an idiot
not to be able to figure out one way or
another how to get how to make money off
of that mm-hmm
for me what saved me was the listeners
they treated I mean I went to a bunch of
people before we started asking for
donations we had done the show four
years before we asked for any donations
or any money or anything and I went to a
bunch of experts I trust in business and
law and a bunch of other areas and I
solicited their advice and said if we
ask the listeners to donate to this will
that work
and every single one of them said not a
chance in hell really really intelligent
smart people and I and I was dissuaded
and I thought oh my goodness all these
people are and we thought well let's
just do it anyway what are you gonna
lose we're just asking the listeners if
you if you think what you heard was
worth the dollar give us the dollar save
up so you have five and then give us
five whatever and oh my gosh that's
changed our lives and so when I talk
about how fortunate I feel to be doing
this let's not forget who I owe for this
a bunch of people who didn't have to pay
we give them away for free they didn't
have to do this I mean it's like what
Radiohead did when they put that song
out on the internet instead of instead
of putting it on the radio or selling it
as a CD and saying just give us what you
think it's worth and it worked out
better now I don't know if this is
sustainable right I don't know if this
is a flash in the pan or whatever but at
the moment what people have done is make
possible professional amateur media I
know that sounds like a contradiction in
terms but that's what we are and and so
I owe a lot of people out there
listening to your show and mine and lots
of other podcast for giving me this
blessing that I do and I mean I talk
about it too much I'm sure it gets old
but I wake up in the middle of the night
and just say thank you you know it's
crazy to me well I'm gonna tone down my
over-the-top praise but I mean it's it's
very clear that you put a lot of effort
a ton of effort and prep into the
episodes which i think is part of the
reason why people are so willing to
donate for instance what has been the
most popular episode to date if you had
to guess or popular episodes they say in
history like if you're the History
Channel for example that the subject
that people get the most excited about
is the Second World War that's why I
think they did it to death on the
History Channel and stuff like that
because it's almost something you have
to screw up to not do well with the only
real time that we've touched that
subject dead on is when we talked about
in a multi-part series the Eastern Front
in the Second World War so basically the
war between the Germans and the Soviet
Union although there are a lot of other
people involved most Americans and I
didn't realize this actually don't know
much about that because
here's so much about the stuff that our
side was involved with that to them as a
part of the war that that essentially
gave us the advantage of stuff taking
that subject that's gold right second
world war its history gold and yet a
part of it that people weren't aware so
it's like finding new world war to stuff
the History Channel ego guess what all
this World War two stuff you haven't
explored yet I mean Oh Mike it's like
finding gold and so we we told this
story and people loved it this is the
ghost of the ostrich those are the
Ostrom yeah Austin is the German word
for Eastern Front you know if you took
and we I think we said this in the show
I can't remember what we said yesterday
much less what we said that but if you
take just the eastern front of the
Second World War and isolate that as its
own war it by itself is the biggest war
in human history all by itself and so I
think the stories that come out of that
and the horrific 'no sand the feeling of
the people who must have been trapped
you know in that dynamic are such that
people listen to it and i think can
really relate and and again having
having a new world war two subjects
especially one that's so big i mean when
you hear that you really understand that
the war was probably won or lost on the
eastern front and so i think it had all
the elements right there to be a really
popular episode if i don't screw it up
right it doesn't seem like you did the
what what what episode did you have i
know how stressful it must be it is
people don't understand it it's become a
lot more stressful than it used to be
all good stuff i'm glad to be doing it
but but we're stressed right now for
example so what whether it's with stress
or without which which episode are
episodes did you have the most fun
personally recording whether it's
researching or recording oh i could
cheat on this answer though because we
did three interview shows before the
audience informed me that they get
hugely letdown when they finally see a
hardcore history show you know after
waiting forever for a new one and
instead of being what they expect they
get an interview show interviews are fun
because you can do them in real time I
mean basically take an hour talk to
someone you you admire for an hour and
then you have a show
oh my gosh I want three months now
working on the latest hardcore history
show so I love that and I get to talk to
two people that I admire like James
Burke but in terms of the other shows I
won't lie to you none of them were easy
and they get harder and I don't know why
I keep doing that to myself I my wife
was saying why don't you just pick a
nice small easy topic and do that and I
don't know why because there's something
about feeling like I'm pushing myself I
mean if I have some creative brain cells
I am using every single one of them I
will not be able to say as I'm laying on
my deathbed somewhere that I didn't push
myself to the limit and on these shows
we'll go from that Mangal series which
like I said I think I left some of my
sanity in the studio and decide to do
the first world war after that
what sort of masochist does that Kim I
think well yeah I think we're cut from
the same cloth oh she was doing the
thinking in this company it's just when
I think I'm gonna have some fun with one
of these things I decide to take on
something that listen there's no
question by the time it's done it's very
satisfying to say hey people like that
we did a lot of good hard work and it
paid off
but while you're in the midst of it and
first of all I'm not sure it isn't gonna
crumble like an airplane crash you know
I don't know that that we're gonna get
to show five and the whole thing's just
gonna fall apart so it's nice when it's
over to know that it worked out but I'm
always feeling like like I'm not having
a ton of fun while I'm doing it but i
but i but I am it's like working on some
big account if you're an account
executive and and you're so happy when
it's over and you go and you toast the
the team you work with and all that at
the end is very satisfying but while
you're in the midst of it there's a lot
of stress and pressure and deadlines and
all that but listen that's life right
yeah nothing's like you always have that
no it's it makes me think of my
experience with publishing where after
each book I tell myself you know the
next books gonna be a short book I
always say that the next books gonna be
a really short book gonna take it easy
cranking off fast be nice and bite-sized
and
then of course after I have some type of
series of nervous breakdowns over a year
and a half or three years someone asks
me well or they imply and I assume the
books must get easier after you do the
first book the second must be much
easier then the third must be just wrote
by that point I say no because I take
everything that I've learned that that
should and could make it easier and then
I just double what I want to do or
triple what I want to do based on that
new efficiencies doing just as much if
not more sounds exactly the same you
know listen from a creative standpoint
you shouldn't want to have it any other
way right if you're the Rolling Stones
and your teeth Richards in that in that
studio on the hundred think you want to
be working that hard because you want it
I mean you know there's an old line that
when you reach the top the only way to
go is down right and so when we hear
that we just did an episode that people
say well that's the best episode you
ever did we instantly think to ourselves
well you don't want to do anything worse
than that that becomes the new minimum
standard right right but and truthfully
if you don't give them something as good
as that next time they're gonna say wow
you know it's not as good as that other
thing so so we always feel and I think
you do too I think everybody does when
they're doing creative work the next
thing needs to be better than the last
thing so you're continually saying oh
sure I didn't go in I almost went insane
the last time I'm going to go and say in
the next time it's the only way to
ensure that I'm I'm I'm pushing the
limits right right yeah the high-water
mark must be surpassed how does Michael
Jackson do better than Thriller right
you know god I don't even want to think
about that but that would be yeah I
can't even imagine the one of the many
things that comes up listening to
hardcore history is military history and
certainly with wrath of the cons the
explanation of different techniques and
approaches like the false flights or the
false fleeing I found endlessly
fascinating in it then it sounds like
that's that's something that has
fascinated you in military history are
there any particular people or
techniques or strategies that you found
most interesting I know that's a very
big I'm thankful that you find it
interesting because I think and again
something for podcasters were we're just
starting out maybe the
pay attention to is if you talk about
what you find interesting eventually you
will acquire a listenership that likes
that too and so a lot of times I'll
wonder if I'm not getting too deeply
military on some of this stuff but then
I realize that the people who are
listening if they're still listening
like liked that military stuff from
earlier episodes that was my focus in
college was military history and so
that's what I've always been interested
in I don't do rainbows and unicorns is
what I always tell people and it's dark
I'll tell you something on your show no
one else even knows Tim wonderful we're
working on artwork for the specific
shows that we've done I've got an
article and it is so dark and our
artwork is dark anyway and I showed my
wife the other day I was so proud of it
and I said honey look at this look at
this art and and she comes over all
excited to see the art and I can watch
her face drop and she goes it's horrible
I said I said you mean it's bad she goes
no it's just so dark and terribly go
that listeners will love it then I said
it'll just be pretty just what we're
after it matches the subject matter
perfectly so I mean but look it's it's
it's what I like and you just figure if
you try to make a show based on what you
think other people will like eventually
you will have a show that you don't like
yeah it's a grommet and so you have to
do what you like and that's why this
Internet is so wonderful and all these
billions of people out there if you only
suck up 1/10 of 1% of the pie of
Internet users that like your weird
stuff that you bring up that translates
into a lot of people I always tell folks
I'm like a street performer really Tim I
mean that's what I do I'm like that guy
the mime on the street corner or the guy
who plays the violin and he opens up his
violin case and you throw pennies on the
street corner to the guy who plays the
violin I just work a really busy street
corner that's what this is is that is
that it you know if you're a niche
market product the Internet is a place
where that niche can can still translate
into a ton of actual people so don't
water it down you know there's a there's
a phrase and we've all heard it but we
don't think about what it means if you
go on television on a TV network you are
broadcasting right you are reaching a
Rod's segment of the audience the
problem is is that to broadcast you have
to water things down and widen them out
to the lowest common denominator we
podcasters are narrow casters not
broadcasters and you can't lose sight of
the fact that that's that's not a bug
it's a feature right now you want to be
a narrow caster and you want to have
this niche that's all yours and so if
you're talking about invisible unicorns
that you see on the weekend make that
yours man unicorn on the weekend podcast
and anyone else who does it's ripping
you off right I saw I told you never to
tell anyone about that I'm really the
Sasquatch's if in my house podcast I
mean that that's how it should be I
don't think that when you're talking
about a program that that you should do
it for other people do it for yourself
in military histories where I live mom I
think the other thing that I have to
keep emphasizing and I don't think you
should be afraid of this - if I've
learned anything from the podcasting
it's don't be afraid to do something
you're not qualified to do mm yeah I
tell the story all the time is that I
didn't come up with the hardcore history
idea I have far too much respect for
historians to have thought that I could
have done that as a history major with a
degree I mean if they're one the history
majors know is how great historians are
because we read them all the time right
so I used to tell my stories so that
I've told my whole life and I was
telling him around the dinner table and
my mother-in-law said to me you know cuz
I was already doing one podcast on
current events and stuff and she said
why don't you do a podcast on the stuff
you're talking about here at dinner and
I said oh I couldn't do that as its
history and I'm not qualified to talk
about history I don't have a Doctorate
I'm not a historian and she said I
didn't realize you had to have a
Doctorate to tell stories and I thought
about that for a minute I thought well
listen most of the great historians from
the non modern era didn't have
doctorates either they're just
storytellers - as long as I'm not
purporting to be a historian as long as
I'm using their work and what I always
will say is let's say there's a
historical controversy I will tell you
the controversy then I will say well
here's what historian a says about it
and here's what historian B says about
it and I
been surprised how much the listeners
like to hear about what's called
historiography which is the process of
how history gets written and made
interpreting they love hearing that and
so you'll actually talk about the
different theories and so I'm not making
this stuff up I'm using the experts to
tell you a story and the stories the
part I'm qualified to tell you oh no I
that that's one of the one of the
aspects of the show that I must
appreciate is that you'll you'll point
out the contradictions and you also talk
about the different schools of histories
you'll have certain types of revisionist
history you'll have different political
leanings and how they interpret events
say in the the spanish-american war
found you know the events in Cuba
fascinating as well as Philippines and
really helping people to realize that
the biases at play in a lot of the
reporting and writing that we might
otherwise assume to be objective perfect
example and we talked about Rome ancient
Rome in the Republic period and you know
the reason that people look at that
period and think it looks a lot like our
own is because you can see some of the
same political dynamics at work broadly
speaking right you know obviously
there's a lot of time elapsed I often
say to people imagine that there's a fox
news in ancient Rome and an MSNBC in
ancient Rome so a left-wing version of
events and a right-wing version of
events because what they always say is
history
journalism is the first draft of history
right so then imagine that only one of
those narratives made it into your
history books right Rome as seen by Fox
News or Roman politics as seen by MSNBC
and how you can tell the Roman story
that way and in it and if you do it and
you contrast the two views it sounds
even more modern so I do think that it
actually sheds light on the events to
point out the different webbing the
apaches a hundred years ago those are
red murderers killing good Christian
white settlers thirty years ago
it's terrible horrible white people
murdering blameless Indian I mean you go
through these periods where the entire
focus and then the public mood changes
and we write history a different way mom
those are fascinating in and of itself
because it also teaches you
that there isn't necessarily truth here
there's just the current perspective
that's in vogue mm-hmm oh absolutely and
I'm actually reading a book right now
called dying everyday which is a
subtitle Seneca at the court of Nero and
it's a very fascinating account of
Seneca that tries to reconcile at some
level the opposing views and mythologies
and facts surrounding this character
Seneca who was a very famous stoic but
at the same time was very very wealthy
some people called him opulent and just
trying to point out the backgrounds of
the people who wrote these histories or
who had these accounts who worse in some
cases his political enemies it's really
fascinating thus far because I'm a huge
fan of of Seneca and Marcus Aurelius and
a lot of these philosophers write the
hedonistic Stoics that's my favorite
exactly see you point out how much money
that's the best kind of stoic to be the
hedonism yes it's like premeditated
spontaneity you know let me if I could
shift gears a little bit ask just a
handful of kind of rapid for our
questions and I'm having a lot of fun we
could do this for a long time but I want
to be respectful of your time and I'd
look to to throw off a couple of
rapid-fire our questions and you can
take as little or as much time answering
them as you'd like you have your hands
in a lot these days you're doing quite a
few different things what are the first
say hour or two of your day typically
look like what are your morning rituals
I've had the same morning ritual for a
long time it's the old talk radio show
host or reporter ritual where I get up
and I'm really gonna summit one of these
days when books and newspapers go away
I'm gonna be really sad because I have
to start with the newspaper like an
idiot nowadays I bring it in
I get the cup of coffee out I start with
the newspaper then I go online if I see
any stories that piqued my interest I'll
print them out I'll put them in a folder
and then the next time it's time to do a
current events program I'll look in the
folder and see you know we're on like
275 of those or something so it's
getting awful hard to find new things to
talk about that I don't feel like we've
already done but I spend the early morn
while I'm waking up the first cup of
coffee or 10:00 catching up and reading
mostly uh current events stuff what do I
do you wake up
oh goodness well it's summer vacation
now here at my house it's based on the
children's schedule so when when it's
school time it's like you know 7:00 a.m.
and we're up and Adam on now I can sleep
a little bit later sometimes but I have
a I have a sweet spot in my production
ability where I'm at my best talking and
it's usually from about like 9:00 to
noon or 1:00 and so that's when I like
to be in the studio I hit like 2 o'clock
and all the coffee in the world is not
keeping them you know and and so that
that's why we're having this interview
now 10:00 right and I remember the
scheduling yeah what I'm dealing with
East Coast people it's really awful so I
try to get into the studio when when
I've got a decent amount of energy and
then by the time I'm out of there and
done then I'm spend the afternoon
getting back into reading research cuz
there's a lot of reading to do and I'm
not I'm not the world's quickest reader
and so I also have a very tough time
trying to figure out opportunity costs
you know one of the things that a lot of
podcasters start to learn once their
podcast becomes popular is you're
running a business now man and that's
not the part that most people yours
truly included thought of when we got
into podcasting right you think about
the product you don't think about the
the edifice and structure that you have
to maintain to keep the product going
right and I'm not gifted at that stuff
and so what people will often say like
on Twitter and stuff and wonder what
you're doing in the three months since
the last time you put a history podcast
out and you can't you can't even begin
to tell them all I mean just the website
alone that I've been working on for a
year is the time wasting that goes on in
my life and it certainly I could do it
better but like people will come to me
and say Dan could you do this or you did
and you get these opportunities thrown
your way because of the podcast and you
think to yourself I can't get a podcast
out in three months how am I gonna take
advantage of any of these other
opportunities that come my way and so so
I'm wrestling with how I do more because
people have given me these chances based
on the fact that these listeners are so
kind to listen to the show I don't know
how to do them I don't know how
on this business so it's all I can do to
get these shows out so when you talk
about how you do these things and I
wrestled with the business side of this
every day to be honest well I will we've
chatted about this before but if I can
help with any website stuff or whether
it's WordPress related or otherwise I'm
happy to I've heard I've I've heard
about your bookshelf balloons tomes
about medieval torture I know how you
operate people promised to help me with
websites
what is the newspaper that you read is
is there one newspaper that you
consistently read yes the stupid local
one here Berg that just gets delivered
to my front door easily and the funny
thing is is everything I read and it's
been printed two weeks ago on you know
the Internet but I still just like some
old person have to do it and I have to
read it all the way to the end of the
comics like some like some person with
OCD or something I just I can't help
myself when I was in TV news before the
internet was doing news I used to get
like five newspapers and you know and I
go through every one of them all day
like an idiot I don't I don't do that
anymore but but just the silly local
paper or my local Berg of it and when
you're when you go online to potentially
find interesting current events or
angles to print out what what are those
sources are there any particular sources
that you repeatedly visit uh well a lot
of twitter has turned out to be really
good way for listeners to share with me
things they think I'd be interested in
and then they get a pretty good idea of
the sort of things I like but no I go
everywhere and I might start with Google
News and then just and I check out all
the British newspapers I check out the
major American newspapers there's some
in Canada and then I like going a
wonderful thing about the Internet the
ability to kind of go local so if you're
reading about stuff between the Israelis
and Palestinians for example I like
looking at the newspapers from the
Middle East I like looking at various
for example if you're looking for the
Israeli side there are different Israeli
newspapers with different perspectives
and so so when I'm delving deep it's
wonderful to have the internet that
allows you to three
mention allies in a way that was not
possible when I was getting five
American newspapers in one day - really
I don't know if you end up being more
intelligent on the subject but you could
certainly give multiple viewpoints does
that make sense oh definitely I remember
my first real extended trip abroad in
college AB this was after being in Japan
as an exchange student but I was in
China and I found the local English
newspapers contrasted with the
International Herald Tribune to be
really mind opening because I'd never
been exposed to extremely different
viewpoints on what I perceived to be
exactly the same phenomena or current
events really was a was a was an
eye-opening experience for me and the
tribunes what we always read when we're
out of the country yeah yeah it was all
I could get my hands on I've been there
what just had completely shift gears
when you think of the word successful
who is the first person who comes to
mind oh my goodness you know Jim I don't
know I thrown some questions at me today
and I'm this verbal person and I'm
usually pretty quick on my feet but I
don't know how to answer that because my
definition of success is perhaps a
little a little different you know I was
arguing with somebody once about
ambition mm-hmm and we were talking
about whether ambition was genetic or
not and we were discussing happiness and
I was trying to make the point that that
successful being successful in life
means you're happy but that some people
have to achieve certain things to be
happy right right so so in other words I
know people who can do nothing in their
lives and be happy with that right so to
me they're successful right hmm but
there's a lot of people who say well no
no no if I if I don't make a bunch of
money or if I don't achieve something or
if I don't create something or or or if
I don't you know if you don't reach
these particular goals then I'm not
happy so in other words success for them
requires in order to be happy requires
that they do these other things to find
happiness so to me being successful is
being happy and so there's lots of
people out there that I think have
managed to be successful who
most of us have probably never heard of
I'll tell you what there's a part of me
that's even jealous of the people that
can manage to be happy without having to
do a bunch of things to get there
absolutely you know yeah I think I mean
people look and say isn't it great
what's going on with your podcast and I
said yes because it makes me happy
not because of any other amorphous or
even concrete goals making this much
money or getting this much notoriety or
whatever you know going on Tim Ferriss
show and having him say all these nice
things about me is wonderful but the
show itself makes me happy and and
that's that's where the success comes in
now if we didn't make enough money to
live I wouldn't do the show so I
wouldn't be happy you know so I mean it
all kind of boils down to the same thing
we need different things to be happy but
happy and successful are the same thing
to me hmm
does that make sense yeah no that makes
sense the roundabout way of answering
your question no no it's very big no
it's a good answer very clever of you
know the what what would be failure to
you then it would it be being unhappy or
is it something is it something else
entirely and that that could even be as
it relates to the podcast if we wanted
to to try to constrain it a bit to make
it easier to answer it here's here's the
worst part about having a podcast that
people think are successful is if you've
never made it successful then you
haven't screwed anything up you took a
chance and you failed and that's part of
life and it's part of learning and it's
part of success actually but if you
manage to create something that's
successful and then you screw it up and
blow it that to me seems much more of a
tragedy at a personal failure than the
never having gotten one off the ground
at all so I I think I was rather
devil-may-care when we started these
podcasts now all I'm thinking about is
if I don't do this blueprints of
Armageddon part 4 and have it be really
good then then I've screwed up the
Golden Goose right so so failure to me
is really you know like Keith Richards
would have said in that Rolling Stones
studio you're only as good as the last
thing you put out so failure is not
putting out a piece of good work at this
point in my mind ya know I definitely
get it I mean think I think especially
with the sophomore act for me at least
the second book brought a lot of stress
with it and it really
feel really under the gun with the set
the perfect example yeah very similar
feeling if you could change one thing
about yourself what would it be
I'd be more productive I think that's
pretty easy I got out of the booth today
in the studio and I didn't have anything
useful I've been working on the same
part for like three days now and you're
just ready to smack walls I mean to sit
there and he's so unproductive even
though you know and I learned this um I
learned this writing as well where you
know I remember writing something and
setting myself a weekly total that I
wanted to hit write and every day I
would like to write this many hundred
words and I would feel productive and
then you would get to the end of the
week and you need to edit what you wrote
and you get rid of 5,000 words or
something and you just you you think to
yourself oh my god what did I waste all
that time for and I think that's that's
how creative endeavors often are so so
like you know you ask me how these
programs go there are days when I'll go
in there and not like anything I do and
just feel like such waste I could have
used that time so much more
constructively had I only known it was
gonna be a wasted day at the microphone
right so yeah productivity I'd love to
be more productive I'd love to be able
to multitask I can't multitask either
don't you think just to touch on what
you just said don't you think though
that sometimes that that day of
seemingly wasted recording is necessary
to gestate yes yes yes get to that one
paragraph there is the one that everyone
quotes you are absolutely 1000% right
and that is what it yes you're fumbling
your way to glory yeah that's my that's
my mo glory should be the name of my
next book you couldn't be more right
about that I keep trying to console
myself saying that it wasn't actually a
wasted creative day even though 500
people on Twitter said where the hell is
the next show Carlin get off the beach
with your mai tai and you know what I
loved him I loved that there are people
out there who literally think I wait
until the last second and then I walk in
in four hours later we have a show and I
was just making you wait I
people think I'm Frank Sinatra I love
those people you know what and I'm gonna
start to cultivate that image that I
really don't do anything until the last
second and then yeah okay I'll give you
a show maybe the night after dinner I'll
crank one out for you talk about making
yourself an immortal legend right I just
do those shows in real time no
absolutely yeah at at one take Carlin
just Franks and not let me know how you
like midnight I keep the band up late
and then I just you know we're out there
with Ana
so speaking of my ties you walk into a
bar what do you order from the bartender
something straight you know I come from
a family on both sides of old-fashioned
men and that's the way to describe them
I don't smoke cigarettes like they did
but it's hard to totally get away from
your roots and they were hard drinking
see they were so much tougher than I am
too
I don't have the toughness but I can
drink like they drank and so so if I'm
gonna sit there if I'm going to go to a
bar and drink I'm going to drink a
straight whiskey or a straight rum or a
straight vodka or something like that I
don't fool around right why you skip the
foreplay
that's right it's a production right so
I'm going with the Sinatra theme that
you said so we talked about Sinatra we
talked about drinking what's the first
face that comes to mind when you think
punchable hi shovel you know I get so
III have see and this is where like if
you get to my old shows on politics and
current events I sound so much angrier I
think when I got into politics as a
teenager I got in it from from and I
think a lot of teenagers when they get
to politics or early college students
it's out of anger you start to see the
world as it's been created by the
generations before you and you just feel
like it's so screwed up and how can they
deal with all the injustice in the world
you know and so that's how I got into
political talk radio for example is just
I was so mad and things that I saw that
we're just wrong in my opinion as I've
gotten older I think I've been able to
see more perspectives and and maybe be
able to walk a mile
the other guys moccasins a little bit
better but so when you say you know
people that you would just want to punch
maybe it's a holdover wanting to punch
them from years and years ago but the
people that drive me crazy I'm gonna
answer this question a certain way we
get downgraded to slap also good
I'm not recraft Attell you that there
was a wonderful series called hell in
the Pacific and it's a it's on the the
second world war in the Pacific Theater
and I think it was made by a British
company and I remember being shocked
because it had footage that we don't we
didn't show much in the United States of
really horrifying Pacific battles and
they interview a u.s. veteran who didn't
die that long ago his name is Eugene
sledge and his nickname when he was in
the Marines with sledge hammer and he is
he went on after he got out of the
service to teach a school of college in
any miss Georgia and he's the most
soft-spoken wonderful sweet Southern
gentleman you've ever met and the whole
hell in the Pacific series starts with
him saying that no one who's even yards
behind the front line in war knows what
it's really like and nobody who does who
hasn't been up there should be able to
send young people off to war you haven't
been and he means right on the front
lines you have no place doing that the
people that drive me crazy are the
people in American politics who are I
mean who see war is the answer to
everything I don't even mean war I mean
some of these John Bolton's the guy I
always use he's the former you a
American ambassador to the UN just
another one of these guys that himself
avoided military service but sees
sending other people to go do that as
his answer to every problem and I guess
that just drives me nuts because as a
guy who talks about military history all
the time and who hears these accounts of
veterans and realizes how often their
lives are forever altered even when they
come home in seemingly one piece you
just want that to be such a a really
well thought out decision when you
decide to have people suck up that that
lifetime of damage for some cause just
like Eugene sledge was saying you know
anyone who's gonna send someone off you
gotta have a really good reason and I
feel we've got a lot of people in the
public sphere that
didn't do this themselves but for any
reason are willing to go send other
people and they just make me angry like
I'm 16 years old and into punk-rock
which I'm still into and mad and and you
do you get Irish and you just I'm ready
to become a stereotypical
you know punch somebody in the mouth and
it's really it's really a piece of me
that's mostly dead now that comes back
and haunts me at moments just at the
wrong time that's it's always at the
wrong time it's always at the wrong
so speaking of punk rock what are the
most frequently played bands or songs on
your whether it's a computer iPhone or
otherwise oh god I go through I go
through phases where I just kill
something you know and I'll just I'll
get back into the dead kennedys and then
it's like two weeks of just nothing but
that until I can't listen anymore and
then I'll move I've never quite
discovered the variety is the spice of
life thing I have to like eat all sushi
for like two weeks until I can't have
any more and that you know and I don't
like sushi but I just it was an example
and that's how I am with music I mean I
would guy back in the days of record
albums the new record album and play it
200 times and then never want to hear it
again or you know so and I like all the
old stuff too when you go back to like
Lou Reed or the seeds or to me even
Jerry Lee Lewis is punk rock to me
that's an attitude not a not a sound
sure so so I just like all those to me
music is about so much more than the
listening experience that's just a basic
philosophy and music is it about the
technical expertise of the musician or
the beautiness of the melody or is it
about tribal drums that get your blood
going and you know and I'm much more of
the tribal drum person than I am about
and I work with a lot of audio people
and and for them they want to hear
technical expertise and wonderfully
crafted and I want to hear something
from the soul you know for sure I'm just
getting into hand drums so I'm all about
the jump it's very it's very emotional
and ancient sword I love it it's a lest
question potentially if you could give
one or two pieces of advice to your 20
year old self what would it be oh I
think about this all the time I remember
coming out of the television station
where I was a TV
reporter and I was working the night
shift and I had just worked on some
stories all day and was just thoroughly
unsatisfied with them by the time they
hit air and I remember walking out of
the station at like midnight and was up
on the top of this mountain a beautiful
place and I remember looking out and
just saying oh my god when am I gonna
like this
you know when am I gonna what am I gonna
really be be happy with the work that
I'm churning out so I look back on that
all the time when I think of where I am
now and just think if I could go back
and just tell myself don't stress about
it it's all gonna work out in the end
wouldn't any of us like to know that
just just tell me it's all gonna be okay
and I can get by in my 20s the twenties
were really really hard for me I thought
and if you could have just said stop
worrying it's all gonna be okay although
I'm assuming it's all gonna be okay to
him
I still don't but I think I would have
saved a ton of emotional stress and
worry I'm a natural born worrier and I
think it would have been nice although
if you told me that I might have relaxed
so much that that reality might never
have occurred so you know that's why you
can't go back in the time machine and
step on the butterfly you'll screw up
everything so I won't go back and tell
myself that Tim because I'll screw up my
future that's right but if there's an
aircraft carrier headed back to Pearl
Harbor you'll at least sit down and
watch the movie I don't know how so then
this this has been a lot of fun I want
people to listen to more of your stuff
what episodes would you like people to
listen to what's the starter kit if you
want to get people hooked I have my own
thoughts but but what episodes of
hardcore history would you recommend
people start with well I wouldn't start
with the really old ones because I don't
think they are representative of what
we've evolved into it's not that I don't
like them it's just I think that people
who liked the really old episodes
sometimes miss the way they sounded and
the people that liked the current ones
don't as much like the old ones so I
start I'd start with something new just
because if you like that you might get
more of it if you listen to the old
stuff you're not getting any more of
that right I think I would simply pick
it based on the subject matter so pick
we have a certain number of shows we
usually leave
the new shows up for a year or two
before we or three before we remove them
to the paid archives so we should have a
decent mix of things we do something
called blitz editions sometimes which
were supposed to be shorter but they
aren't shorter because I'm too
long-winded but but they just they
turned out to be about slightly
different focuses so instead of focusing
on an event one of the blitz editions
that we did focused on you know were
people in the old days tougher than we
are and I think I think the question we
asked is could you beat your
grandparents in a war and then we did
another one on I think we called it
intoxicated priority oh no history under
the influence we called it and it was
the hidden effect of intoxicating
substances maybe on the past and so
those are the way blitz editions more
look at weird subjects like that and
then the other episodes look at
historical events so I would say pick
one that sounds like it's an interesting
piece of subject matter and then keep
your fingers crossed that we that we
pulled off that episode halfway decently
and I think that's how I would do and
that's the that's the gateway drug into
hardcore history I would say for those
interested in my my personal
recommendations I have yet to dislike
any of the episodes I think wrath of the
cons is is outstanding if you're
interested in in warfare and tactics and
the lore of not ginga's con but jenga's
con i guess it turns out all right then
I I think that's a fantastic series the
prophets of doom I gotta say I know you
I know I know you weren't happy with it
for whatever reason I know you have your
reasons but tell you why I'll tell you
why because I was saving that story that
is one of the great twisted history
stories of all time and I remember
thinking to myself okay you are halfway
to a good show before you say your first
words with this story and so I had
really high hopes for how great because
it's just the story itself is so
wonderful you don't need Dan Carlin to
make it too much performance anxiety I
really enjoyed that episode you teased
the hell out of it in the beginning I
gotta say I was I was getting antsy for
a little bit in the very beginning but I
was giving you context though you have
to understand the
Reformation for that thing to make sense
oh no I love the Reformation but the the
lead is fantastic I'm not going to give
away too much of the story when there's
too much setup so I'm gonna let people
explore where can people best find you
on the interwebs where would you like
people to find you online listen you can
you can get the free shows from our
website at dan carl ENCOM they were
obviously on iTunes as well you can get
the old shows off our website I think
they're a little cheaper off our website
but you can get them on iTunes as well
type my name into the search engine
somewhere the right things should pop up
I listen I'm just happy you're sharing
my stuff with your listeners I
appreciate that thank you oh my pleasure
this I just having attempted to do some
form of a podcast myself now for a
little bit and having listened to a lot
of podcasts the amount of effort that
you've put into each of these episodes
is I think magnitudes of order better
than most audiobooks and that's saying
I've listened to hi this is the real key
the real key is that we live in an era
where we can do this stuff because I can
tell you right now you look at
podcasting and there's about 20 or 30
really creative podcasts out there that
you would never be allowed to do in a
million years in the movie twenty years
ago and yet when you listen to the music
it's just brilliant right and so if
we're lucky enough to be in that
category where you go oh gosh this is
something that would never be in the
mainstream media and I'm so glad I found
it then we're really fortunate I lied to
me that's as somebody who came from that
media and by the time I left it was so
the opposite of creative the fact that
we could we've got this blank canvas
where we could be creative again what a
great time to live right oh it's amazing
it's amazing I mean you've got you know
everything from of course what you might
expect like the This American Life to
say welcome to night Vale which is like
one of the weirdest things imaginable
which is a stands I mean always in the
top 10 on iTunes it's a hell of an open
playing field and like you said
narrowcasting it's it's it's just ripe
for the picking people can be as weird
as they want to be and they'll find
their audience if they're passionate
enough about
so listen if you're gifted I always
think about it this way can you imagine
someone as gifted as Eddie Murphy when
he first showed up on the comedy scene
or Richard Pryor when he first showed up
at the comedy scene if they simply you
know the the mic can be bad the audio
can be bad you might not get shows out
very frequently but if Eddie Murphy were
simply doing a podcast today when he
first started out that would be his
ticket to fame and fortune without ever
needing to make it on a Saturday Night
Live first or anything like that I mean
this is this is direct media to the
public we've never had it like this and
I'm not even sure it's gonna last this
is this may be a wonderful little golden
opportunity in human communication take
advantage now if you've ever thought of
having a podcast it's a good time to get
in yeah absolutely well well then this
has been a blast I really appreciate
your time I'm going to continue to
listen again to the entire series wrath
of the cons which I use for my morning
walks everybody everybody me I know I
know you're gonna start getting weird
letters from me soon but I recommend
everybody check it out
and if you've ever thought of starting a
podcast well maybe now is the time to do
it and I'll be writing a lot more about
that so Dan I appreciate it I will I
will talk to you soon and really good
hanging out thank you very much
continued success you're doing great all
right thanks man I'm uh I'm just I'm
still in the training wheels but I'm
learning as I go
so thanks thanks again I'll talk to you
soon anytime
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog calm calm
where you'll find an award-winning blog
tons of audio and video interview
stories with people like Warren Buffett
and Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park the
books plus much much more follow tim on
twitter at twitter.com/dspacestv or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening
you